okay let's get started with the second
talk of the afternoon the speaker will
be eric bled who's going to tell us
about the analysis of partially
symmetric functions
favorite problems and conjectures and
property testing
and also along the way i want to talk
about the connection to partially
symmetric functions
so there might be many different ways we
can
define what we mean by partially
symmetric functions
so the way i'm going to define it i'm
going to try to convince you as natural
and a nice way to think about it so to
do this i'll start with a simple
exercise pick your favorite complexity
measure whether
computational complexity learning
testing anything you want now think of
the simplest functions that
according to this complexity measure
i i'm willing to bet that whatever
you've thought of constant functions
will have the lowest complexity measure
okay so that's not very interesting
if i were a bit more adventurous i i
would guess that juntas also have very
low
complexity under whatever you're
thinking so when we think of simple
functions especially in this room here
or in this workshop the semester juntas
often come to mind
something that would be more risky and
really depends on what you're thinking
of is i might say that symmetric
functions are simple so for many
complexity measures symmetric functions
do have small complexity for others
that's not true at all
but now this is kind of the picture i
want to think about for now we have
these constant functions and two bigger
classes of functions that are
still simple in many
settings and the question is is there
something that we can define that
actually encompasses both of these
classes of functions
and this is what we're going to call
partially symmetric functions
and more specifically the way i kind of
want to do this i want to think of
partially symmetric functions as the
analog of juntas for constant functions
so what is ahunta one way to think about
it is that
it's an almost constant function there's
only k variables somewhere k coordinates
that as long as you fix them then the
function you get is constant no matter
what var values you hear
the hyun does so
presumably once you fix the k then it's
symmetric
so for the hunters if you fix the k you
get constant and then we want the same
thing where if you fix the k you get
something that's symmetric instead of
constant
and this is how we can define this we
can say f is n minus k symmetric
if there's a set of k special variables
where exactly this happens or another
way to say this if any two inputs that
agree on those k variables and have the
same hemming weight on the rest of the
variables
they have the same value under f
i'm going to call these partially
symmetric when k is a constant
you might look at that and you might say
this is very nice from a computer
science point of view but let's think
about things in a more algebraic point
of view
you know we're talking about symmetry
here so
here's another way we might approach the
problem
of defining partial symmetry we might
say permutations on the set from one
through n
define actions on boolean functions by
just
relabeling the input variables
and so we can now look at a given
function
at the set of functions we obtain under
every possible relabeling of the input
variables
and we'll call this the isomorphism
class for f
and now if our original function f was
perfectly symmetric then
we still only have a single function any
relabeling doesn't change anything so we
might want to say okay this is great
let's call a function almost symmetric
or polysymmetric
if the number of functions we get is not
necessarily one but it's fairly small
and the parameter that ends up being
nice for this definition is to say if
the number
of distinct functions you end up with
this polynomial in n
and this is comparing against n
factorial which is the largest number
possible
so we're talking about much much much
smaller
now what's interesting here and perhaps
another vote of confidence for the
definition of partial symmetry that we
saw before is that if you start with
this definition of polysymmetric you
really are studying partially symmetric
functions as we defined them in the
previous slide in hiding specifically
your function f is polysymmetric if and
only if it is n minus k symmetric for a
constant so if it's partially symmetric
okay so this is a nice definition what i
want to do is i want to
show you that
it also shows up in computer science in
fairly natural settings i'll give you
three examples of that the last one
being the one that i really care about
and which will lead to the open problem
and then the second part of this talk
i'll kind of review some of the tools
that we have to analyze these partially
symmetric functions and where we might
want to extend those tools to actually
prove
or get answers to these open questions
but now let's start with okay where do
we see partially symmetric functions
uh it turns out we've seen them in
computer science for a very long time
the first occurrence of them are in the
classic paper of chloe shannon on the
circuit complexity of boolean functions
this is the paper where he showed almost
all boolean functions have
exponential circuit complexity so 2 to
the n over n
now this was the first part of the paper
where he proves this lower bound in the
second part he kind of says
this doesn't really make much sense
empirically because on a day-to-day
basis all the functions i see have much
smaller circuit complexity why is that
and the first thing he points out which
was actually based on earlier work is
that well oftentimes it's because the
functions we try to implement
are symmetric and if your function is
symmetric you don't have exponential
circuit complexity you have only n
squared is enough
and then he also gave a universal upper
bound that applied to all boolean
functions and this universal upper bound
immediately gives you a constant size
upper bound if you're a junta on a
constant number of variables so we saw
these two classes of simple functions
are simple in this circuit complexity
model
the natural question to ask and the
question that claude shannon asked is
what about partially symmetric functions
and indeed those are also very simple
and this is not very hard to show once
you have
those two results in hand you can
actually combine the circuits for juntas
and for symmetric functions in a nice
way to get
a polynomial in n again upper bound for
constant k or even for
small enough k
this result he did not even state no
so this one is it follows from his
universal upper bound
um
yeah slightly disappointing but
it was too easy at that time that
for for this result only
um
let me mention one one other example uh
another thing we can say in terms of the
circuit complexity of partially
symmetric functions is that if you're
partially symmetric you can be computed
with a constant
constant depth threshold circuit
so you the function is in tc0
and this was a theorem and not an
observation of clothing
chronicus but only because they were
interested in the polysymmetric
definition that we saw so most of their
work really involved just trying to show
that if you're polysymmetric you're
partially symmetric and once you have
this partially symmetric again this
result just like in the circuit
complexity is very easy to see you can
play around with it and get it
another reason i wanted to mention this
beyond the parallel is just because it
it's actually very interesting it has
other connections to other fields
including proof complexity which i don't
know here so i'm
putting in quotes what i think is the
main result here but from what i
understand
potassium santana had this new model of
effectively p simulations for proof
systems and they had this conjecture
that maybe uh
it has these nice results like
uh that frigay could simulate extended
frigate under this new system that they
introduced but using this theorem they
could actually show limitations on
theirs on the the simulation model that
shows that actually probably this
conjecture that they were hoping for is
false
so again this uh it's exactly partially
symmetric functions that show up in this
setting as well
okay and now the star of the show
is this testing function isomorphism
problem
let's take this
very basic problem that i'm going to
give you i'm going to give you a truth
table for some function f
and i'm going to give you a black box
that computes some function g
now for starters let's say that the
question marks are filled in that i've
labeled the input wires
and now i ask you if g computes f
and i'm even going to make your life
easier in the standard property testing
sense that ryan alluded to earlier i'm
going to promise you that either g
computes f perfectly or that it's
completely off it makes errors on a
constant fraction of the inputs
if you have these
input labels on the wires this task is
really easy you just query random inputs
and check against the table to make sure
that you get the right value
as soon as i take away those labels on
the input wires this problem becomes
very interesting
now you're asking the question of
whether there is some
labeling of these input wires that i can
choose where the function g computes f
or whether any labeling that i choose i
still end up far from the function f
and now the question of how would you
test this black box g against the known
function f
becomes more subtle it's unclear
what exactly you would want to do and in
fact it will depend on what the function
f is
if i want to write this definition in
words the exact same problem that i
stated here i'm going to say we're going
to define a tester that makes q queries
to be some randomized algorithm that has
access to some function g
and it knows some function f and in
particular it knows the list of all the
functions that are isomorphic to f
and it just has to distinguish with high
probability between the cases when g is
actually isomorphic to f
or when g is far from all the functions
that are isomorphic f
and the main question the question i
really like is can you tell me which
functions for which i can test
isomorphism
with a constant number of queries the
number of queries that does not depend
on n
and in particular maybe i want to dwell
on this just a second
why do i like this question the real
question i'd really like to answer
is not just for isomorphism testing
against the given function but for all
properties of boolean functions and in
my mind properties of boolean functions
they're just properties that are closed
under relabeling of the input variables
and in the sentence we can think of
these isomorphism problems as the
smallest properties that are closed
under the sense and if we can solve this
main question i feel we'll have made a
lot of progress towards this general
question
uh so now that i've
well maybe i should
this really is the the question i want
to sell you on so i should stop and ask
if there's any questions at this point
okay
great question
that's exactly what i was hoping for
um
yeah so we have these two simple classes
of functions so let's ask if we can test
isomorphism against them the first one
are the symmetric functions actually
here
uh we're back to the function identity
testing problem because it doesn't
matter what input labels you put on the
wires in the original black box problem
so that's trivially easy we can test
isomorphism against them
and then a non-trivial result is that
you can also test
uh isomorphism against juntas with with
a constant number of queries
and the fact that this is a constant
number of queries was uh due to fisher
kindler ron saffer and samuranitsky who
also proposed this function isomorphism
testing problem
for the first time i believe
but okay so we have symmetric functions
we have juntas
do we also have partially symmetric
functions yes this is a result
obtained with amit weinstein and yuichi
yoshida last year and in parallel work
independently by czech reborti fischer
garcia soriano and matsuya if you're
partially symmetric we can test
isomorphism to this function with a
constant number of queries
what's really nice about this the the
other applications or the appearances of
partially symmetric functions before
that we saw the proofs that they were
simple were
they were easy proofs they were not
particularly interesting proofs this on
the other hand turns out to be
uh more technically interesting so there
are
nice things that come up and we actually
need to understand a bit more what it
means to be partially symmetric in order
to prove this result
i'll
i have the main theorem that gives
the main technical theorem that lets us
prove this as the last thing for this
presentation if we have time
um
but before we jump to that i kind of
want to ask okay
what's the next step
we have partially symmetric functions
let's move on let's get something even
bigger that includes everything
uh the punch line we couldn't find
anything
we do not think that there is anything
essentially
so we think we have this conjecture and
again these two papers that were done
independently both came up with the same
conjecture
that
we believe
any function that's far from partially
symmetric is hard to do isomorphism
testing against and here i put log k but
really what i mean is it's a function
that's going to grow with k so if you're
not close to partially symmetric on a
constant number of variables
well so
it's going to be a function of k but
i i kind of want to say either you're
going to be close to
n minus k symmetric for k constant or
far for something slightly super
constant
oh that's arbitrary
because i was not brave enough to put k
in here
no no no i wanted to write a little
omega of 1 as a function of k but
yeah this is really what i mean i i want
to say that this will grow as a function
of k that's that's the real conjecture
no uh okay so why does it have to be k
and n um
i can have a partially symmetric
functions on on on three variables
that's going to be far from being
partial for k equals three which is far
from every n minus two symmetric
function very far from it
so in this case
yeah so this might not be the the best
statement uh
uh
but the the punchline is that that yes
if you're really not partially symmetric
there should be an n dependency on the
query complexity
the second part of the talk is
kind of explains why i'm talking about
this here i kind of think that the tools
we have here and that we love exploring
are the tools that we need to prove this
conjecture
and just to give you a quick overview we
do have some connections to influence
and to some of the other tools that
we know and love and i'm just going to
quickly run through
what we what these tools look like what
we do know
uh the first thing that we know is that
if we take the natural the usual notion
of influence and of total influence and
perhaps this not as standard definition
of the influence of a set of variables
which is just the probability that you
flip the value of the function if you
re-randomize all the bits in this set
if you look at these three notions of
influence and you ask can we do the same
thing that measures
not influence in terms of
where where this notion of influence is
really used for juntas and constant
functions can we do something similar
for symmetry and partially symmetric
functions and we can
and the right way to do this is instead
of looking at the influence of a single
variable
by flipping the variable now we want to
ask about the symmetric influence of a
pair of variables i and j which is just
the probability that you flip the value
of the function by interchanging the
values of x i and xj
you can define total influence in the
same way as before by just summing up
the individual influences
and we can do again the influence of a
set of coordinates by just saying now
instead of re-randomizing each bit and
this set s we're just going to permute
them uniformly at random
okay so if we define these tools do they
help us can we say anything interesting
about them
we can
and we can even visualize what they look
like really they're measuring the number
of bichromatic edges
on a graph that corresponds to the
function it's just a different graph
where now two points are connected uh if
they're related by just a transposition
instead of just flipping coordinates
but let's look at some facts okay some
easy facts
if your function is symmetric the
symmetric influence
is zero which is what we would like
we can represent the influence of a pair
of coordinates in terms of fourier
coefficients of the function which is
nice
and we can even prove some really nice
theorems like
what was mentioned this morning uh ryan
and carl's result that we can prove kkl
for this symmetric influence where now
instead of saying that f is balanced
we're saying if f is far from symmetric
uh then we do have a pair of coordinates
where the influence of this pair of
coordinates is large as log n over n
and then
for the testing problem that i mentioned
earlier it turns out what might be even
more relevant is the other notion of
influence of a set of variables and here
again we can say some non-trivial and
slightly interesting things
so again we have this nice result that
nice obvious but the you know this is
what we want that
if you're n minus k symmetric it does
mean that you have a set of size k where
if you look at the symmetric influence
of the remaining coordinates it's zero
we have again this fourier
representation of the symmetric
influence
and we have these two facts that mirror
the
the same facts that we have with the
standard notion of influence the first
one is that the symmetric influence is
monotone
if you
add the number of coordinates that you
consider in your set you can only
increase the symmetric influence it
doesn't go down
sub-additivity is something that holds
for standard influence where now if you
look at the union of two sets you look
at its influence
it's bounded above by the sum of the
influences of the sets this is no longer
true
with this notion of symmetric influence
but it's almost true in the sense that
if your sets are large enough
the symmetric influence of the union of
the sets is almost bounded bounded up to
some factor that depends on the size of
the sets
by the sum of their symmetric influences
and what we'll see is that we can
actually use this to prove the upper
bound result to prove that partially
symmetric functions are
testable
and this is actually
the one main result that i want to talk
about the one that implies the theorem
that we can test these functions
efficiently
and what it is is essentially a robust
version of the first fact that we saw
the first fact that we saw is that if
you're n minus k symmetric there's a
size
uh there's a size case set where the
remaining influences have uh the
remaining coordinates have influence
zero
there's the converse if you're epsilon
far
from
partially symmetric
you can
for any set that you identify the
remaining coordinates will have
symmetric influence at least epsilon
and what this theorem says is that we
can say something even stronger
so now instead of just picking a small
set of size k and looking at the
symmetric influence of the remaining
coordinates i'm going to say
let's be sloppy let's just partition all
the coordinates into k squared different
buckets
and now instead of picking k coordinates
i'm going to let you pick k buckets
so that you can try to minimize the
symmetric influence of the remaining
guys
and no matter how if we pick this
partition at random no matter how you
choose these k parts the remaining
coordinates will still have influence
symmetric influence that's linear in
epsilon so still very large
now
the reason i mentioned the proof here
really the main message i want to
bring is that we couldn't prove this
with fourier analysis
the analogous statement for juntas is a
free and it's a simple proof using
fourier analysis
and when we started this project we just
really wanted to have the same proof we
couldn't make it work this would be one
of the challenges so already for the
problem session it would be great to
have a proof of this theorem that just
uses fourier analysis
but the proof that we got used instead a
surprising connection with intersecting
families
and so i'm going to run through this
proofs this proof has essentially three
arguments that i'm going to make and if
i can back them up then the theorem
follows
and the main idea of the proof is just
to say let's look at all the sets that
could be bad for us let's look at all
the sets where if i chose that set the
remaining coordinates have very small
symmetric influence and very small at
first will be epsilon over 3.
the first claim that i'll back up in a
second is that this is just not any set
the set has to be k plus one
intersecting any two sets in that family
must have intersection size at least k
plus one
now once i've done that we're actually
almost done because then i'll say
there's two possibilities either this
set has this family has a small set
inside of it
in which case i'll give you another
simple argument to show that
this means that
any
with very high probability any k parts
will satisfy this condition that the
remaining coordinates have very large
symmetric influence and on the other
hand if there's no small set then i can
actually kind of boost this by looking
at the
the family of even worse sets that whose
complements have even smaller influence
and i get a larger intersecting larger
guarantee on the intersection size
and the reason i want to do this is
because now i'm going to bring in the
intersection theorem uh originally of
all suede and kachatrian but we're going
to use the dinner and safra version
which says that now if you pick a random
set uh
with some p bias
the probability that you end up in this
family is going to be extremely small p
to the intersection size
so
let me just
quickly show you why these should be
true
um
and then this will give you the proof
the first statement why are the bad sets
and intersecting family is essentially
just because of sub additivity take any
two sets that you have look at the their
intersection size
now we can use
uh
de morgan if i did it correctly
and then sub additivity with some factor
for the fact that sub additivity doesn't
hold exactly but we get the bound that
this influence of the coordinates
outside of the intersection is less than
epsilon
but the only way this can be because f
is far from n minus k symmetric is if
that intersection has size bigger than k
otherwise i could choose that set to be
the set of core coordinates in the n
minus k symmetric function that's really
close to f
so this gives me the intersection
the second argument is the easiest one
that says that if you have a small set
and you have a partition into enough
parts this set is going to be
split it's going to be shattered each
element in the set s will go to a
different part
but now any way that you pick a union of
j parts
you're going to have intersection size
at most k with this set we just argued
that it's k plus 1 intersecting all the
bad sets have pairwise intersection at
least k plus 1 which means that j cannot
be a bad set
so again the conclusion holds
and then this final step the first part
of it is exactly the same argument we
used in step one
and the last step is just the
observation that if i fix any k parts
say you take the first k parts of the
partition that you're going to get
before you do the random partition
and you ask what does this set look like
it's just a random set and the density
is going to be exactly k over the number
of parts that i have k over k squared
it's a random 1 over k
biased set
and so now we apply this intersection
theorem to say the probability that it's
in this
family that has very large intersection
size is going to be extremely small so
small that we can actually apply now the
union bound overall potential ways to
choose a k of the k squared parts
and this is the proof but again the main
message here was really just
can we do this with fourier analysis
instead
um
essentially because i would like to
understand how these tools help us
understand partially symmetric functions
better so right a fourier analysis proof
by itself does not give us anything more
but
i am hoping it brings us closer to
solving resolving the conjecture
in fact let me just close with some open
problems here um
just some obvious open problems the
first one is even if you don't like
function isomorphism testing i hope i've
kind of convinced you at least a little
bit that partially symmetric functions
are kind of nice they're a natural class
of functions it would be great to
understand them better
are there any results that we can have
that we have over regular functions that
we can get analogs
when we look at partial symmetry so for
example again this morning we we saw
this already as an open problem
suggested can we get a fried ganjunta
theorem over non-product
domains this is a very nice natural
non-product domain it does have a very
natural notion of what it means to be a
junta it's just partially symmetric can
we prove friedrat's junta theorem in
this case
we have a lot of results on the
structure of the fourier spectrum of
if i were bold i would make that
conjecture but to be honest i just
thought of this yesterday
it just hit me yesterday that yeah we as
far as i know we don't even know this
for this partial symmetry
so that you you swap to two guys at
london when you say that if the sound of
this influence is small then you're
close to partially symmetric yeah that
should be
that seems like a reasonable conjecture
that
we can name this conjecture
if it's true i'll happily accept yeah
or i'll try to disprove it very quickly
if it's uh obviously false
um
yeah so i mean
one of the reasons i mentioned it also i
hesitated to mentioning this because i
was thinking it might actually be known
and this would be embarrassing but on
the plus side
i would definitely know after this talk
someone here would know if this is known
so if there is anything like that that
would be great uh yeah the structure of
the fourier spectrum we have lots of
things for symmetric functions we have
lots of things for hunters what can we
say about partially symmetric functions
that's non-trivial and potentially
interesting
and
you know my
motivation for this is can we actually
use these tools that we develop or even
the ones we already have to actually
settle this conjecture about function
isomorphism testing
and then the other you know the general
question is
is this a more general phenomenon do
partially symmetric functions actually
occur in other areas where we just
haven't really realized it and i guess
the natural place to look at would be
places where
you know symmetric functions and juntas
do have low complexity under whatever
measure we're looking at and it's
already been used in a couple settings
so i just want to mention local
deconstruction reconstruction
and this alternative model of property
testing or these different models where
partially symmetric functions were
actually a natural class of functions
that showed a separation between
four different testing models where you
allow more and more power and you get
strictly fewer queries needed
in each model
and so that's it this is what i wanted
to talk about
any other questions right
are there lower bounds with k log k up
about
for testing
uh
that's a good question there might be a
k lower bound but i'm not sure right now
for juntas there is the k lower bound so
testing isomorphism to hunters is
between k and k log k
this is a comment
partially symmetric functions also
appear when
you try to do lower bounds for symmetric
linear programs
this is great yeah
as partially symmetric functions
excellent
excellent we have to talk more about
that
okay so
recognizing that when two functions are
moving yeah
you can ask a weaker form of equivalent
where
you don't just permute the variables but
you apply
some linear transformation yes is there
some work on the
recognizing when two functions are
yes
that that's a great question and it has
been studied very recently including by
carl
uh so this is like testing under yeah
linear transformations
and it ends up
that's a great question
in part because it ends up being more it
appears to be more tractable we we
appear to be making more progress on
that
um
the specific results they have
i mean you should probably step in but
they have results showing that for some
functions you have very
strong lower bounds on how many queries
you need so
you can give a universal upper bound and
they give matching lower bounds i don't
know if there's work on is there work on
characterizing the set of functions
we have something
that's kind of similar and sort of a
similar state that we want to show that
if you're epsilon far from having say
small spectral norm
then it's hard to test isomorphism
we do have the general case though i
mean there's a very naive n squared
tester with the problem because there's
just like there's a naive n log n tester
for permutation isomorphism we also have
a lower bound of constant times n
squared many queries
and this is but you cannot test linear
isomers into the inner product y2
function with less than constant time
that squared many queries so unlike the
extreme case like the linearized modulus
the problem is resolved
a
okay